hello and welcome to this video playing
or eve an all-new or be violent six days
all be gone not will be one that's
important I guess ok big decision on
often I please have now you can do many
things them also just canceled ok this
is this is imprecisely have seen in
numerous games right now and has the
ideal information you can play out just
on the queenside or play with g 4-h for
its more ambitious even i'm doing
they're doing the queenside thing let's
see what he does just play for before
[Music]
Wow to put it on a six okay so Queen a
three I guess I'm 2345 check
okay so if i go Bishop f2 Queen g5 then
I cannot castle g3 he will go to h3 and
it's it is slightly annoying
maybe okay and not sure maybe I should
have gone to be to what they're okay but
that doesn't threat anything okay wants
to go with the bishop to h6 I guess
Mary Queen side is completely falling
apart white white wins material him only
have to avoid yeah blundering into some
stuff Bishop a six now I can also play
tags but it's a big it's a four-piece oh
please let's take it so here I can also
check the night f8 I guess just just
this is right I can still check
it seems he definitely wants to take yes
somewhere I'm like one f2 or so yeah ok
I'm going to yeah check him so let the
night probably has to withdraw and now
he doesn't threaten all that much right
Knight takes this check yeah probably
this is the right move make the Queen
move and now maybe Queen g4 so that the
Queen simply get traded should be a
relatively easy way to do it or let's
say risk-free way to do it there was
probably something more powerful I mean
I'm fairly certain about that but
tend to be cautious and I have lost the
number of those games where like black
was lost like after movie 11 or so that
really was the case here and then all of
a sudden I overlooked something stupid
and then lost the game so so want to try
to be precise but did this now looks
doable even with my visual and
technicalities sc7 just fall yeah there
was a this was the worst possible Kings
Indian basically it's um it's already
wrong to allow this if white managers
this setup without having Castle black
is in trouble it really is the case the
computers evaluation valuation is even
22 too good for black the thing is they
i simply stay on Iran I don't ever
castle a king side and the role I here
on the queenside is extremely quick and
five is a cruel move by the engine but I
don't have to take right I can also do
this so this is what the computer yes
but why do I need to isn't that the game
almost almost here bishop age 6 okay so
then there are some more subtleties that
I wasn't aware so I should not judge so
I should just cancel it's a little bit
like deja vu like a headless to form
keep getting cold say I have to check
what's on the phone I'm sorry about that
just a second yeah so I'm back let's
check that I'm kind of curious there so
and five so i should not I should cancel
him okay of course bishop age six or
something but this looks kind of weird
yet to put it on a seven well i mean i
get i get c5 in he cannot trap this
anyway I mean like this doesn't work
probably I can take that I have courses
on his head okay look a window
[Music]
queen bee 295 m interesting so be sure
h6 was really was really a lot better
yeah I cannot I mean usually I would
want to keep the picture but that that
really doesn't work check check check
and that also is probably no good and
now now things go as as they should on
the green side so I have to be precise
it's important here not playing with f3
but but just careful how I usually I'm
in this position I usually don't play
this a 3 before I usually play g4 and
then this this kind of thing which also
is pretty good but I wanted to try the
queenside plan this time it will find
that there's an important Morty that
Bishop h6 move is really a problem ok
guys thanks for watching